des autos immobile inutile un pont fermé
à la circulation automobile est réservée
aux piétons et aux vélos
l'industrie du transport motorisé est en
panne depuis deux mois le prix de
l'essence est une aubaine mais faire le
plein pour aller où
les pompes à essence services essentiels
sont bien rester ouverte pendant le
confinement
mais maintenant les stations-service
attendent la reprise avec impatience
selon l'association des distributeurs
d'énergie du québec les ventes d'essence
ont baissé de 60 à 75 % selon les
endroits
surtout dans le réseau autoroutier les
détaillants qui vendent autre chose que
de les sentir mieux dépanneur lave auto
service et réparation s'ils retrouvent
leurs employés qui préfèrent parfois
toucher l'argent du fédéral
l'apc vue plutôt que d'aller travailler
du jour au lendemain les ventes de
voitures sont tombées à zéro freddy en
sait quelque chose il installe des
systèmes de sécurité non un espace de 24
h non mon ventre sont allés à 1 0% ont
complètement arrêté tout notre réseau de
distribution
ils ont été fermées et aussi les
concessionnaires alors si a pas de
ventes de véhicules y a personne qui va
se rendre dans notre réseau de
distribution nos partenaires d'affaires
plusieurs concessionnaires automobiles
sont en difficulté il ya des risques de
faillite
l'association des concessionnaires du
québec a mis au point un protocole de
retour au travail avec toutes les
précautions sanitaires nécessaires
il y a déjà quelques temps mais le feu
vert pour la réouverture s'est fait
attendre
les grands ports d'amérique du nord
ressemble à ceci les inventaires
s'accumulent
ils ne seront pas faciles à écouler et
cela dépendra d'une grande inconnue
la cadence de la reprise économique qui
elle dépendra de la tournure de
l'épidémie c'est pas facile pour les
concessionnaires automobiles
si on regarde le côté positif c'est
qu'au québec il ya plus ou moins 60% des
véhicules qui sont loués alors le monde
que les véhicules viennent à échéance
vis-à-vis leur location
ils vont être obligés de reprendre un
autre véhicule alors de cette phase est
là les saveurs et des books ou les
concessionnaires les grands
constructeurs automobiles viennent de
reprendre le travail comme cette usine
de camions de fiat crès le dans le
michigan où on espère calmer les
inquiétudes des ouvriers qui ont
pratiquement tous repris le travail au
mexique aussi dont dépend une grande
partie de l'industrie nord américaine
le travail a repris c'était une priorité
mais les constructeurs sont pessimistes
toyota s'attend à un effondrement de 80%
de son bénéfice opérationnel 2020 2021
avec une chute de 20% des ventes
mondiales
l'aco vide a aussi des effets inattendus
dans le secteur contrairement aux années
antérieures le volant à la tripler les
vols de véhicules pour nous à la triple
et je vous dirais que depuis le 15 mars
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a eu trente de
vol de véhicule tous retrouvés bien sûr
le traçage des véhicules volés
l'application des normes d'assurance
plus le service des systèmes de sécurité
ont permis à s'accompagner de compenser
un peu le manque de ventes
jean michel leprince sera du canada
montréal